بعد عامين من القيود التي فرضتها كورونا
تعود اعداد الحجاج الى وضعها الطبيعي دون
قيود او شروط وبنفس الاعداد لمواسم ما قبل
الجائحه فوفقا لاخر الاحصائيات الرسميه
لجايحات كورونا فقد وصل عدد الحجاج لعام
2019 الى نحو مليونين ونصف المليون حاج
لكن ماذا عن الاشتراطات المرتبطه بالتحصين
للحجاج القادمين من خارج السعوديه وزاره
الحج والعمره بينت للعربيه انه يشتر تلقى
الحجاج ثلاثه تحصينات ضد كورونا ضد الحمى
الشوكيه اضافه الى لقاح الانفلونزا
الموسمي وهو ما ينطبق على حجاج الداخل كما
اعلن سابقا وتشهد مدينه جده استمرار اعمال
اليوم الثاني من معرض ومؤتمر اكسبو الحاج
بمشاركه واحد و80 متحدثا من القطاعين
العام والخاص ووفدا من سبع وخمسين ولا حول
العالم للعمل على تحسين تجربه الحجاج
ونعود لنذكر مشاهدينا بما اكده وزير الحج
والعمره الدكتور توفيق الربيعه ان حج هذا
العام لن يشترط فيه حد اعلى لاعمار الحجاج
والذي كان مقررا في العام الماضي عند 65
عاما كما كشف الربيعه خلال كلمته في معرض
اكسبو الحاج عن تخفيض تكلفه التامين على
حجاج هذا العام بنسبه ثلاثه بالمئه لتصبح
عند سبعه 87 ريالا فقط
يسرني اليوم
بشارتين
في هذا اللقاء
البشره الاولى
عوده اعداد الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل
الجائحه وبدون اي قيود على العمر
بعثه من اي دوله في العالم عاده ترتبط
بمؤسسه خدمات واحده
في خدمات الحج
ولتعزيز التنافسيه
الان وابتداء من هذا العام اي بعثه الحج
اي مكتب حج من اي مكان في العالم يستطيع
التعاقد مع اي شركه مرخصه تحقق المتطلبات
اللي يحتاجها حجاج هذه الدوله